I’m announcing my candidacy
for president
for president of the United States
for president of the Unites States of America
Lots of people want to be president
It’s going to be so much easier the second time
I’m repulsed by lots of politicians.
They pander to get our attention.
To the new moon squad
Alright
Mayor Pete! To the road ahead
She’s 20, I’m 52 this is not fair!
[laughing]
A former prosecutor laughs with radio hosts
while lying about the music she liked in college.
Oh my goodness oh yea definitely Snoop, Tupac.
But Snoop and Tupac
didn’t even perform when she was in college.
And when they did,
she was busy imprisoning people on pot charges.
Abraham Lincoln complained that politicians
are driven by a “voracious desire for office.”
Well it’s not better today.
Not only are they mad for power, they push bad ideas.
So here are some of this current candidates’ worst:
[mail truck sounds]
Are you ready for the Post Office to go into banking?
Bernie Sanders claims the
Postal Service could make billions of dollars a year
by establishing basic banking services.
Really? The people who mishandle mail?
Oh my God are you kidding me?
The Post Office just lost another billion dollars.
Now they’re going to manage our money?
Sanders also wants
A ban on for profit charter schools
Why? Sanders says
I believe we do have a moral obligation
to lift up the poorest people
But Sanders would freeze funding
for even non-profit charters,
like this one that helps kids succeed
after government schools failed.
Reading is work, but it’s rocking awesome!
Sanders should listen to his colleague Cory Booker.
When people tell me they're against
school choice or charter schools,
I look at them and say as soon as you're telling me
you're willing to send your kid to a failing school
in my city then I'll be with you.
Sensible, but unfortunately, that was years ago.
Now that Booker is a Democratic candidate,
he’s quiet about school choice.
Instead, he wants the government to guarantee
everyone a job and to pay many people’s rent.
We're going to have a very aggressive renter’s credit
The bad ideas keep coming.
Senator Gillibrand wants to force everyone
to buy fertility treatment insurance.
Real, structural change
Elizabeth Warren plans to change all kinds of things
the cancellation of student loan debt of up to $50,000
She’d also ban all oil and gas drilling on federal land
Our very existence is at stake
Closing that pay gap.
[APPLAUSE]
Kamala Harris wants companies to
prove they pay men and women equally.
There will be penalties if they don't.
[APPLAUSE]
But salaries vary for lots of reasons
unrelated to sexism.
President Harris would also censor the internet.
We will hold social media platforms accountable
for the hate infiltrating their platforms.
That sounds nice,
but if politicians get to decide what is “hate,”
they’ll censor any idea they don’t like.
The 1st Amendment is one of the defining features
of who we are
Good for Joe Biden for saying that,
but he’s got bad ideas, too.
College should be free.
Free? Colleges already jacked up tuition much
faster than the rate of inflation because
taxpayers subsidize too much of college.
China! China! China!
The Republican front-runner has bad ideas too.
Our trade deficit in goods with the world
last year was nearly $800 billion dollars
We lost on just trade 800 billion dollars
No Mr. President! We didn’t lose $800 billion.
The “trade deficit” just means foreigners
sent us $800 billion more goods than we sent them.
We got products. In return, they got this paper,
which they’ll invest in the US.
So that’s good for us. It’s not a problem.
No it’s crazy what they’re saying,
so many different things
Fortunately, the incumbent has some good ideas too.
We eliminated 30,000 pages of job killing regulations
from the Federal Register.
Now the president says he wants to shrink
the code to its 1960 size.
This shows how
many rules we’re burdened by now.
Some Democrats also say sensible things.
Mayor Pete Buttigieg criticizes his opponents
for their “college for all” freebie.
I have a hard time getting my head around
the idea that a majority who earn less because
they didn't go to college would subsidize
a minority who earn more
And all the candidates could learn from
congresswoman Tulsi Gabbard.
She served in Iraq and says
she knows the cost of war.
I will end the regime change wars.
Taking the money that we’ve been wasting on these
wars and weapons and investing it
and serving the needs of our people.
But sadly, she wouldn’t give the money back
to the people.
She wants to spend it on other
big-government programs.
All the candidates have bad ideas,
but some are worse than others.
Let us know in the comments below
who you think has the best and worst ideas.